>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: For Dr.
Carla Hayden, Librarian of Congress.
Each book is a story each story
is made of glistening letters
and letters the ones
grandmother wrote
in late night singing each song
is a long comin' home journey
that was written in the first
ever morning when we walked
into freedom each freedom climbs
the mountain where you stand
and remember all the ones that
stood up with faces painted
by a million suns triumphant
voices ushered
by a marching new dawn written
writing and walking giving
and giving each dawn again
and again giving books
of courageous love There it is.
[Laughter]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at Loc.gov.